[Música]
y seguimos en directo américa para
hablar de salud para ello ya está
conmigo en el estudio más romeros a la
mar feliz inicio de semana feliz lunes
es para usted desde que comenzó la
pandemia varios gobiernos decidieron
imponer medidas muy restrictivas para
así eliminar el cubit 19 un año y medio
pues estas políticas han cambiado porque
pues la situación epidemiológica del
mundo y también de estos países está
cambiando mucho por eso hay algunos como
australia nueva zelanda que decidieran
abandonar un poco está este objetivo de
eliminar totalmente el comité y pasar a
otras a otro tipo de políticas y
precisamente para hablar de eso estamos
como cada lunes con el doctor a carlos
eduardo pérez médico infectólogo de la
universidad nacional de colombia doctor
muy buenos días cuéntenos qué se
necesita para poder implementar este
tipo de estrategias de eliminación total
del cob y 19
mal es muy importante saber que se
necesitan varias acciones uno conocer la
enfermedad y su dinámica y controlar la
propagación dos que las vacunas no
solamente prevengan la enfermedad sino
corten la transmisión y tres que hayan
medicamentos efectivos en la actualidad
las vacunas nos protegen de la
enfermedad pero no cortar la cadena de
transmisión y eso ha limitado la fase de
eliminación que se haya implementado
inicialmente en algunos países doctor lo
saludo muy buen día la pregunta entonces
qué beneficios hemos observado que tiene
esta estrategia
digamos las estrategias en durante una
pandemia raúl tienen una fase de
preparación una fase de alistamiento una
fase de mitigación y una fase de
eliminación
hoy estamos en esa fase de mitigación en
donde nosotros hacemos todos los
esfuerzos para minimizar el impacto de
la del 19 pero la fase de eliminación es
que ya no hayan más casos y para eso se
requieren vacunas que tengan un nivel de
eficiencia superior a las que tenemos
actualmente pero hay varios países como
decíamos como australia como nueva
zelanda que ya han decidido relajar las
restricciones que estaban manejando y
dejar un poco de lado ese objetivo de no
tener ningún caso de kobe 19 porque han
decidido tomar esta decisión ahora
la evidencia nos ha mostrado que
definitivamente primero cerrar fronteras
no cierra el oído gente porque la
dinámica y la migración humana es muy
importante las nuevas variantes han
afectado negativamente las vacunas en el
modelo de cortar la cadena de
transmisión y eso ha hecho que estas
fases de eliminación pues sean grandes
recursos económicos con poco impacto en
la salud pública en este momento es
concentrarse en la mitigación y
reformular la vacunación para que haya
un control efectivo de la transmisión y
así llegar a una fase de eliminación que
será un proyecto a mediano plazo y sobre
eso es mi segunda pregunta de doctor y
además que pues creo que ya también se
dieron cuenta usted me corregirá que el
coi 19 ha llegado para quedarse por
mucho tiempo entre nosotros entonces se
preguntó cómo hacer esta transición de
unas políticas para eliminar el coi 19 a
poder controlar la hora
claro la fase que viene seguramente la
fase de endemia la fase de endemia
quiere decir que ya no nos afecta a
todos los humanos ya no todos somos
susceptibles lo que va a ver es re
brotes o por la aparición de una
variante o por zonas no inmunizadas y en
adelante vendrán vacunas y medicamentos
que eliminen el virus cuando estén acá
tengamos disponibilidad de esos
medicamentos de esas vacunas entraremos
a la fase de eliminación que será una
fase a mediano plazo por ahora tenemos
la fase de mitigación es vacunación
tratamientos y disciplinas ciudadanas
doctor una estrategia como la que
decidieron implementar en australia
nueva zelanda también en china por
ejemplo mi percepción es que requiere
muchísimos recursos también de rastreo
de cuidados serio hubiera sido posible
de tener ese objetivo de kobe pero en
países de américa latina por ejemplo
probablemente no porque definitivamente
la inversión de recursos en cuanto a
tamizajes aislamientos y vemos que
nuestras economías son basadas en la
informalidad distinta a las de otras
regiones hacen que sea muy limitado ese
control social que se necesita además
del control farmacológico e inmunológico
por lavado por las vacunas entonces en
américa latina debemos estar a la
expectativa de mantener nuestra
enfermedad lo más controlada posible en
esta fase y mitigación del problema para
cuando hayan nuevas alternativas
terapéuticas poderlas implementar pero
vamos a tener por lo menos unos 5 ó 10
años de escribir
hoy pero aprenderlo a manejar como
cualquier infección respiratoria que
hemos hecho durante todo este doctor y
último nueva una última pregunta ya que
volvíamos américa latina' efectivamente
están funcionando esas estrategias de
mitigación de las que hablan en la
región
parcialmente porque básicamente hay una
indisciplina social que todavía no hemos
logrado
superarla por decirlo de alguna forma y
las presas de vacunaciones están
implementándose pero todavía las
coberturas no llegan a los 70 80 por
ciento de las poblaciones como en otras
regiones del mundo
por eso digamos que esas fases son de
mitigación están parcialmente
implementadas en los países y
necesitamos acelerarlo por lo menos
antes del fin de año y en los veranos la
superior de vacaciones para que no
tengamos la amenaza de nuevos brotes y
pues estar acostumbrados también como le
dijo el doctor marc 5 a 10 años viviendo
con el código 19 no tocará que nos
acostumbremos y que aprendamos también
todo lo que podamos doctor también
gracias a usted por estar con nosotros
en este espacio de salud como todos los
lunes ahora vamos nosotros con este